Je me demandais juste si tu voulais euh tu
sais sortir un jour tu veux prendre
un café maintenant oui maintenant
je vais juste m'accrocher
quand je me réveillerai bien je sais que je vais être
son nom est Sadie
je veux dire je sais ça  ça a l'air fou, je pense que c'est
peut-être elle qui
t'accompagne, elle est vraiment géniale,
tu verras
chaque mot qu'elle leur adressera, je parie qu'elle
n'a même pas vu ton texte, elle
voyage beaucoup pour le travail, va la voir.  Je
vais à Londres, je
vois que tu comprends, c'est un grand
geste romantique qui est incroyable, mon pote, 5 000 miles
pour surprendre une fille que tu n'as rencontrée
qu'une seule fois, surtout si c'est elle qui
a fantôme ouais non
non, elle ne m'a pas fantôme, elle le
fait juste  Je n'ai pas de plan d'appels internationaux, d'
accord
[Musique]
d'accord,
où suis-je, oh mon Dieu, tu n'as pas le bon
gars. Je suis un ancien, attends, attends,
[Musique]
étranger,
c'était un geste romantique,
amène tous les chasseurs de primes dans le cockpit que je
veux.  sa vie
est plus grande que toi et moi,
il ne t'est jamais venu à l'esprit qu'il pourrait être un
atout étranger essayant de compromettre ta
mission
étrangère
[Musique]
crois-moi, c'est une blague